نسخه مشاهدينا طبق الاصل من ايطاليا ومن
روائعها عثر عليها مخباه في قلب غابات وين
ويلز في بريطانيا
هذه بايطاليا بس هذه الايطاليه طيب في
داخل هذه المدينه الصغيره وجد الباحثون
مبانا ايطاليه شهيره بدءا من كتدرائيه
فلورنسا ومرورا بجسر ريالتو في البندقيه
وصولا الى قناه البندقيه ذاتنا
طبعا هذا كله طبقا لموقع فقد اصيب
المحققون في الموقع بالصدمه الحقيقه من
العدد اله
ائل من التي وصل عددها الى 200 قطعه
اطلق او اطلق على الموقع المكتشف اسم
ايطاليا المصغره التي ستصبح مزارا للعماره
الايطاليه في ضواحي ويلز جميل جدا
مش كثير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات